alors nous allons sur la pelouse du
jardin de l'élysée retrouver le remix
insolite du nouveau du côté des
tricolores véronique et bien oui vous
pouvez l'entendre la faille est depuis
quelques secondes la chanson wild
champion's a démarré alors vous je ne
sais pas si vous les voyez mais les gens
chantent dans se tiennent par les bras
et les tricolores les bleus sont là les
héros du jour sont là sur le perron avec
le président de la république qui vient
les rejoindre vous entendez j'imagine
mais on aurait crié de joie et
d'allégresse la musique la musique très
fort et plus tous ces applaudissements
qui éclatent et les voilà envoyé le
président de la république qui arrive
sur le perron il est entouré donc par
les footballeurs il a rejoint une pique
à pied
l'ambiance est très détendue tout le
monde sur la pelouse applaudi les gens
m'ont envoyé sur les épaules les uns des
autres pour essayer d'apercevoir que la
fed
on a du mal à imaginer qu'on est à
l'elysée quand on voit là la liesse
populaire à ça il faut reconnaître que
c'est pas une ambiance très fréquentes
ici mais ça y est vous et là c'est quoi
tu changes dont la coupe du monde non
plus un pion jumeaux nés là le président
de la république est extrêmement des
temps durs la musique au plus fort
je vous laisse écouter l'ambiance parce
qu'elle parle d'elle-même on dira tout
le monde est uni tout le monde
abandonnez les petits fours et le
champagne
voyez les bras qui s'agite le premier
ministre a rejoint le président de la
république
voilà tout le monde chante maintenant
tout le monde change le plus quand la
république le premier milieu
freddie mercury du groupe queen qui a
marqué cette coupe du monde 98 - et
c'est très surprenant d'entendre ça dans
la cour de l'elysée hier dans le jardin
de nouvelles côtés de laurent blanc
boghossian cité la bise
avec tout le staff technique nous a
rason franck leboeuf 6
magnifique défenseur qui a remplacé
laurent blanc de la halle au pied levé
et je crois que le président de la
république s'apprête à prendre la parole
nous allons les couper
bien et selon jeu une seule ombre et
secondes
je voudrais je voudrais saluer au nom du
gouvernement en mon nom et au nom de
toute l'équipe de france
tous les jeunes nés 4000 jeunes qui
viennent de la france entière
elles deux la france entière de
métropole des départements et les
territoires d'outre-mer et je leur fais
un cadeau le plus beau cadeau qu'ils
puissent rêver l'équipe de france
l'équipe de france et la coupe forment
l'acronyme obama
faute du monde et en votre nom à tous je
voudrais leur dire notre admiration
notre reconnaissance et notre amitié
ils sont la plus belle image que vous
garderez de la france de cette année
dans votre coeur et je vais demander 20
ans à celles qui ne sont pas pour peu
dans cette victoire
c'est à dire à leurs épouses de bien
vouloir nous rejoindre avant guerre ces
dames de venir
et c'est vrai qu'on les a acquis les a
vus tout au long de ce mondial ces
femmes qui étaient dans les tribunes
pour soutenir leurs époux qu'elles n'ont
pas vu beaucoup pendant les deux mois de
préparation va ici les les bout'choux
qui sont avec elle et qui seront donc
sur la photo souvenir
en ce 14 juillet 98 assez exceptionnel à
tout parent
merci mesdames merci pour ce que vous
avez fait car il nous revient une part
importante de cette victoire
voilà alors tout ça est très peu
protocolaire véronique ça ne ressemble
pas trop photos de gouvernement qu'on
voit d'habitude écouteurs voilà c'est du
jamais vu ça à l'elysée on n'avait
jamais vu une foule aussi dense des
jeunes aussi enthousiaste qui toute
politique mise à part il faut bien le
dire comme unis dans une même ferveur
pour leurs sportifs et jacques chirac
n'est pas direct mais n'est pas en rêve
vous voyez une lève le bras
il sourit il acclame ils adorent
organiser les poteaux de famille ça vous
allez voir il va donc le faire lui-même
mais légion en place une journée
extraordinaire
l'équipe de france est très fier d'avoir
remporté cette coupe du monde
elle est très fière de voir toute la
population française heureuse et nous
sommes tellement fiers d'avoir réussi
notre pari quand vous le tome 7 doublons
vous appartient
voilà aimé jacquet qui la font nous
attend et qui reçoit aujourd'hui un
hommage mérité à l'elysée en souvent de
presse nationale voilà didier deschamps
capitaine
excusez moi je peux la boîte et qui est
diminuée je voudrais au nom de trouver
les joueurs vous remercier de tout votre
soutien durant cette coupe du monde et
c'est vrai comme l'a dit aimé jacquet on
est champion du monde mais vous aussi et
toute la france est championne du monde
bercy voilà le team du capitaine qui a
dû lui aussi se coucher tard la
république qui a risqué a essayé
d'imposer le silence pour qu'on
l'entendra mais c'est ça bien alors là
c'est quoi sinon aulas qui démarre alors
là c'est pas encore une eau à l'arrêt
vous voyez tout ce sont des
applaudissements les
nous faut que re ils ont envie de
montrer le faire savoir il fait
quasiment des bronziers c'est la leur
dont ils vous disaient aux communes et
dans un même enthousiasme
à -cg pas politique mais il s'agit
vraiment de ferveur nationale autour de
ces footballeurs qui il faut bien le
dire sont les héros du jour
combien y at-il de personnes véronique
estimations jacques chirac lui-même a
annoncé 4000 jeunes alors ses 4000
jeunes sont venus de toute la france et
même des pays francophones
ils ont été choisis pour leur
leur intérêt pour le foot royal préside
la république s'est passé à son tour de
la coupe du monde il a bondi à me
l'avait promis qu'ils sont ramenées pour
la remettre et de ce point de vue là y
compris la partage avec aimé jacquet
au micro alors le président demande le
micro il a encore un petit mot ajouté
peut-être on reste avec vous à ces
images sont magnifiques c'est un moment
exceptionnel que nous vivons ensemble
d'imagés sont iniques et elles sont
exceptionnelles
allez un p'tit coup de queen encore très
du mercury
zinédine zidane
le héros de la finale
je parle parfois des jades alors je
voudrais rester simplement dire que vous
remercie de votre soutien qui est fait
tout le soutien que vous avez porté pour
peut-être toute cette coupe du monde et
maintenant elle est là au moins pour
quatre ans donc on va la garder et on va
faire encore la fête très longtemps mais
merci merci à tout le monde
voilà ils ont pas l'air de vouloir
arrêter faire la fête c'est positif ça
ils n'ont pas l'air de vouloir quitter
l'elysée du tout isolé a dit ville de
vouloir y passer toute leur après-midi
lors les buffets sont bien garnis le jus
d'orange et le champagne coulait à flot
les petits fours aussi il faut bien
reconnaître que pour les courses à nu ce
ne sont pas les buffets qui intéresse on
va continuer le son là on a cru marquer
que les petits fours c'est un flop en ce
moment oui non là tout le monde et tout
le monde a les yeux tournés vers
l'estrade où les vers l'estrade vers les
marches vers le perron de l'elysée où
jacques chirac est entourée des prix
color on attend on attend un petit mode
là un petit mot de l'autre pour
l'instant personne ne bouge elle
apprécie toujours la tête
j'imagine que les photographes ont
immortalisé l'événement et qu'on
retrouvera sa dent dans tous les
journaux et on va peut-être les garder
parce que c'est vraiment du temps de jeu
et c'est tout à fait ce corps et voix la
président de la république qui partage
la vedette avec avec tous les champions
les champions du monde économie mais
jacquet vous voyez mes jacques est à
côté du président de la république qu'il
essayait de passer
vous passez quelques marches mais
alamar visiblement dans les jambes
buffet une solution on reconnaît se fait
dans une atmosphère extraordinairement
bon enfant il n'y a pas du tout de
protocole le service de sécurité et
réduit au minimum
on a le sentiment que tout le monde est
heureux d'être là et qu'aucune course
neuf ne peut de fait tâche et la peur et
on a vu marie george buffet qui a qui a
assisté à un bon nombre des matches de
cette coupe du monde et à tous ceux des
tricolores elle était comme de nombreux
mondes du gouvernement au stade de
france dimanche soir pour applaudir à
cette victoire incroyable face à face au
brésil alors là visiblement se déplacent
peut-être vers les buffets cette fois ci
est temps de manger 14h15 comment s'est
éteint entouré par les entoure et donc
par les joueurs ou se dire ce qui a fait
évacuer parce que il ya un monde
absolument incroyable et il se dirige
vers
la couse de l'elysée enfin ce qu'il en
reste la pelouse et qui est bordé donc
des deux côtés par des par ces fameux
buffet dont on parlait tout à l'heure
alors une autre musique un concours
tiendra ça aussi on les écoute ensemble
véronique avait justement je parlais de
la musique qui repart la ccc l'un des
hymnes de cette coupe du monde
voilà qu'on se retire à la musique joue
plus dur alors les jeunes frappant dans
leurs mains
agite des drapeaux ceux qui le peuvent
essayer de toucher d'approché président
de la république ou là ou là des
footballeurs tous les membres du
gouvernement sont a bien sûr beaucoup
moi vous pouvez aussi d'hommes
politiques d'opposition on a vu philippe
séguin qui est un passionné de foot donc
marie george buffet qui suit président
de la république
j'essaye qui essayent la chambre à chaud
et pas seulement cours pour madame
buffet choc pour tout le monde
oui j'ai l'impression que le service
d'ordre un peu du mal à servir la ferme
j'ai l'impression ces services nous
sommes abandonnés oui on voit au pouvoir
a carrément abandonné on ne veut rater
immergé dans la cour au milieu de tous
ces jeunes
on a vu un képi partir un peu de travers
à palerme est content que ça se passe
comme ça
voilà robert pires qui signent des
autographes
peut-être au monde de la garde
républicaine dans est pas lui milan
demandera peut-être plus tard
mais c'est à croire cette présidence a
gagné la coupe du monde tout le monde
eut fait la bise
mon au total partage cette émotion l'a
pas déçu à l'ats christian karembeu
avec arlette qui demande un autographe
peut-être et oui mais oui
ah bah ça faudra qu'on lui demande de
nous montrer à voile à arlette chabot
toujours dans notre cas à christian
karembeu
au mieux ces abandons
soit plus bas pas très loin binebine qui
gagnent eux aussi 6 2
ah ça vaut cher car deux buts en finale
de la coupe du monde note howard de
zidane
les collecteurs
j'ai l'impression qu'il il s'en va
maureen dor kf
philippe séguin grand amateur de foot
dp hier sur les champs elysées
saluer le passage du bus
impérial l'équipe de france avait pris
place avec la coupe du monde il était la
flip sa garde à vue a conduit un
triomphe des français aimé jacquet qu'on
reconnaît vague non loin
possible
alors vu la mêlée j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus du football mais c'est du
rugby là alors absolument il y a
également aujourd'hui à l'elysée les
deux les deux équipes de rugby les deux
équipes finalistes de ruby l'équipe de
perpignan et l'équipe du stade français
et puis à d'autres footballeurs et alors
il ya deux autres équipes de
footballeurs l'équipe de lens qui a
gagné la coupe france et l'équipe du psg
qui est donc champion de france
à moins que ce soit le contraire
véronique à ça peut-être c'est le psg
gagner la coupe de france et lens qui a
éveillé les championnes et champions de
france moi l'argent c'est gentil alors
ce matin on nous avait dit vous savez on
ne sait pas très bien comment ça va se
passer ça dépend le président souhaite
s'adapter à la situation mais on le voit
on voit qu'ils s'adaptent il prend son
temps il va serrer des mains
il avance tout doucement des gens autour
de lui continuent de se bousculer pour
l'apercevoir et s'apercevoir aussi les
footballeurs qui l'enfant était bien le
dire voilà aimé jacquet qui est sur les
talons jacques chirac on les prend
l'idée de la foule
c'était annonce
ces images sont étonnantes étonnante du
président un peu chahuté et de très très
très sympathique évidemment par la
ferveur mais vraiment au dedans dans le
palais de l'elysée on doit pas voir ça
tous les jours voilà je crois même que
c'est la première fois j'ai l'impression
les abris publics à ne pas en venir
voilà il ay la sortie d'une mauvaise
passe aujourd'hui tous les pans d'une
photo
voilà marie george buffet qui raconte sa
traversée
stéphane dinars sous les 1 terrasse lui
aussi a participé à cette finale
ils sont d'autant plus méritant que je
le disais le début de ce journal ils ont
passé une foire est très longue qui en a
suivi une autre elle aussi très bien
on a l'impression qu'ils sont toujours
aussi frais et dispos regarde aimé
jacquet qui répond aux interviews de
faire il serait dispo mais ils n'ont
plus de voix
encore cette musique
cette musique qui restera comme un après
je suis inquiète
banny qui voulait être qui aurait pu lui
être gardien de but finalement c'est un
peu comme si j'avais participé ici même
un ballon regardez c'est formidable
signée jacques chirac
mais ballons tricolores il paraît qu'on
n'en trouve plus dit bas
les dés pourtant à 500 francs à peu près
ce ballon de la coupe du monde il paraît
que tous les magasins de sport sont en
rupture de stock on n'en trouve plus
nulle part ça s'est arraché vendus comme
des petits pains
souvenir d'une coupe du monde gagnée par
la france se monte à jouer à voir ce
ballon et pourtant il n'y a pas autant
de footballeurs que ça et on commence la
musique passé magnifique t il à la barre
alors j'ai vu tout à l'heure une
négociation faisant rentrer une entre
deux personnes l'une voulait échanger un
schéma contre deux joueurs de foot ok
juillet un marché qui va dire espère
thierry meury
à la thierry henry qui lui aussi sont
des autographes ici du côté des ulis ça
doit leur faire plaisir de voir la
réussite de ce joueur
je veux aussi à participer sur cette
technique de france et ils signent des
autographes et ils ont pas fini à mon
ami pendant de longues années encore à
mon avis on va leur en demander des
autographes
en tout cas on n'oubliera pas cette
équipée
et cette succession d'imagés
extraordinaires qu'on a qu'on a vu
pendant ces 48 dernières heures depuis
le petit filet finale jusqu'à
aujourd'hui sont tout aussi étonnante
aussi magnifiques les unes que les
autres
bon véronique j'imagine que maintenant
on va on va se diriger tout le monde a
essayé de se diriger vers l'est vers les
buffets pour collationner un petit peu
je crois maintenant que l'idée c'est de
cette fameuse photo de famille
c'est à dire que le président de la
république regroupent autour de lui
l'équipe des bleus et qu'enfin on us
immortaliser ces journées et toute cette
ferveur dans une photo historique bien
bas véronique on va on va conclure sur
ces images cette photo historique vous
la verrez sans doute dans vos quotidiens
demain matin c'est un c'est un très beau
moment que nous avons vécu ensemble un
nouveau grand moment de ferveur
populaire pour ce 14 juillet 1998 et
c'est sur ces images que nous allons
maintenant nous séparer images en direct
de l'elysée c'est la fin de cette
édition que je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi dans un instant la météo puis le
tour de france le sport continue sur
france 2 merci à tous
à demain 13h au revoir